hi where's the Ingham family where are
you
stand up okay what I want to say is this
is the 33 third time that I've made the
decision whether to have an academic
ceremony outdoors or in and I took the
advice of the Ingham Ingham family thank
you sir yeah sit down be quiet now so
thank you father Rick who's new and who
turns out to be a praying fool thank you
david whele and the provost my name is
Larry Arne and I work here at the
college normally I would be introduced
by David but I'm truncating today David
usually says bad things about me anyway
I also congratulate the physics
department who told me that it was going
to rain and to call attention to
themselves they're sitting on such
ostentatiously under umbrellas right
down there it proves the great truth
that nerds can be vain too doesn't it so
instead of telling you the many things I
have to tell you and telling you why
they're true I'm just going to tell you
what they are you'll learn why they why
they're true the first one is the
college is old it's a wonderful thing
about it it was founded by heroes and
wise people you should read their story
we will talk about it a lot while you're
here they founded it just like the
United States was founded according to
principles that claim to be eternal and
that means that we could not change it
except to make it into something
different and we do not feel the power
to do that nor will you have the power
to do that
knowing what it is you have come here to
do what it does
welcome that's why we can have a
partnership what it does is easy to stay
to say the college believes in human
freedom and the governance that
contributes to that it has fought for
that for a hundred and seventy-three
years the College believes in the
in faith it believes that religious
freedom is a high principle and those
who are here who are not of that faith
are welcome as full members and will be
loved and respected there three in this
freshman class who are children of old
friends of mine and I promised them
favoritism and I promise they will not
like that it would be good for them in
the long term to you parents I say we
understand how a child is raised we
understand that we're only here to
complete that we understand what you
have done that understanding by the way
is manifest in the fact that your child
will say goodbye to his girlfriend or
girl or boyfriend before they go to bed
at night
that's an old institution here under
some considerable pressure the way the
world is going and we intend to maintain
that institution and everything like it
you are welcome here the most important
thing we're going to accomplish today is
just in a minute you're going to stand
up and take a pledge to help us in this
work and we are going to rely upon that
pledge we are going to give you
information your child will not like it
perhaps that we send the grades of your
child to you I once had a girl say I'm
23 now and I put myself through college
and still you send my grades to my
parents and so thereafter they were
refused they were addressed to the Vera
to the parents of the very mature
raylene Kucinich the founders of the
college were moral people they tried to
live upright lives think what that means
you must become Stern and steady in the
face of pain that's not easy
that's what courage is you must be
prepared to forego pleasures that's what
moderation is you must be just to other
and yourself that's what justice is and
that means not taking for yourself what
you do not deserve and appreciating
rightly so far as you can what others
deserve and finally you must become wise
this is I'm told the smartest freshman
class we have ever admitted it's very
their qualifications are just awesome
and so they are now going in the next
four months to give the most vivid
exhibition of the distinction between
intelligence and knowledge that we have
ever seen around here finally to use
your students we are here quote the
articles to improve your minds develop
your minds and improve your hearts that
means the moral and the intellectual
virtues you're about to go through
stages one of them is wow this is
serious the next one will be how can I
ever learn it the next one will be this
is a lifetime activity is it not it's a
way to live not a position you will not
get very far if you do not give yourself
to that way with the intention of
maintaining it all the way until you die
and as you grow older and wiser and more
knowing then you will come to understand
why we attribute only to God and the
Angels the kind of knowledge we would
love to have on the night before finals
which is to understand everything all at
once we don't get to do that we have to
work the final thing I will say to you
freshmen is apart from that we do love
you already
if you fail we're going to take the
attitude that we have failed if you need
help we're going to give it but we do
not make the standards around here they
exist in nature
we are going to try to help you meet
them you
must take this attitude about your work
everyone depends on it you can learn
nothing at any moment when you are not
working and just as bad you cannot help
others if you do not prepare that's why
you have the honor code that's why it
you have been warned that this is not
easy I will let the cat out of the bag
it's a lot more fun than it is painful
we hear the faculty over there including
my puffed up physics professors they're
going to be I'm tolerable now after this
we love you why it's so much fun to
watch you because you've reached your
you're thinking maturity now you just
don't have any experience and so
everything you do you're doing for the
first time including this and this day
it is delightful to watch we are
enthusiastic experts at torturing the
young and so I welcome you with the
words that I have said now 17 times is
the last words I say at this ceremony
get your boots on welcome
you